you grew up with Bowie he's my buddy he
was my buddy people don't know that
either mm-hmm that's another death that
had a really rock that had a rock your
world like crazy yeah that was I was
unexpected because Dave's a very has
always been a very secretive about
what's going on career-wise and and his
personal life and everything which I
totally understand did he confide in you
that he was sick he didn't even confide
in george underwood who it was me
george and dave that were at school
together him and those two were in my
dad's art class how old were you when
you met Bowie 11 or 12 11 or 12 these
stories just drive me crazy that you
guys all know each other and that you
played on all things must pass and and
you played with Bowie it's an incredible
story it's incredible life David Bowie
at 11 years old is one of your good
friends because your dad was an art
teacher yes and taught Bowie uh-huh I'm
close were you guys like would you hang
and play guitars and stuff yeah in uh at
school we'd my dad would say bring your
guitar you can play in lunchtime you
know so he we'd stash our guitars in his
office and go and get him at lunch -
sounds like your dad was a great guy in
the sense that he was encouraging in the
arts how many yes you would have that
understanding yeah he was luckily he was
a liked of well liked teacher too which
is just he was he was a born teacher and
he loved it that was his badge so you
weren't embarrassed when Bowie and you
were like hanging out with your dad and
your dad was the teacher like he didn't
make you feel like a douche no oh that's
so great so you and Bowie would you know
play guitars together did you recognize
that Bowie had something back then or
did he just seem like one of your mates
I wanted to be him the grizzly was I
thought he was why he was three years
older than me and they were teaching me
him and George did the George Underwood
is did Ziggy Stardust cover and I
believe one other you know so he's a
phenomenal illustrator so it was the
three of us and they would they would
teach me Buddy Holly songs and I teach
them the latest you know shadows Cliff
Richard number or something and so it
was that's what it was when years later
and you saw Bowie creating that whole
Ziggy Stardust character
everything and he was I don't even say
androgynous I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was yeah was that shocking to you
because no no no no no because I knew
Dave and that was always him he was like
well he was unafraid at school to walk
around and like you know stock oh no no
no he the the only thing he did at
school was this was the year before I
went to the school so and my dad comes
home on a Monday afternoon and he goes
you know darling talk to my mom
darling I tell you there's a strangest
thing with Jones David he said on Friday
I could have sworn he had eyebrows and
he just over the weekend shaved them off
that was what was great about it yeah he
didn't chemist [ __ ] no and he was always
reinventing him so I love that guy